la nuit baisse nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale est en campagne
dans les yvelines les 12 candidats sont
aujourd'hui connus grâce à un travail
débuté avant l'officialisation de l' des
coupes nationales on a eu ce réflexe
d'aller bosser ensemble de réfléchir
déjà à la question d'aider des
suppléants comment on pouvait renforcer
nos campagnes les uns les autres et ce
soir je me réjouis que presque toutes
les sensibilités des yvelines était
présente douze circonscriptions pour
cinq formations politiques différentes
les trois quarts issus de la france
insoumise unis nous gâchent pour
certains candidats de découvrir ou
redécouvrir le territoire yvelinois
j'étais étudiant à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
je suis très content plus de dix ans
après de revenir cette fois en candidat
à une élection et en disant si vous
m'élisez si vous choisissez une majorité
de la nouvelle union populaire à
l'assemblée nationale qui mélenchon est
premier ministre eh ben on va donner les
moyens aux jeunes de pouvoir faire des
études vous savez quand on est militant
politique on est partout chez soi pour
mener les combats parce qu'en réalité
aujourd'hui sur la 8e circonscription
des yvelines je suis le seul candidat
qui propose de défendre la retraite à 60
ans l'assemblée nationale et qui sera
présent pour mener toutes ces batailles
pour la justice pour le climat pour la
démocratie je trouve trop volonté
entendu les gens se plaindre de la
désunion et puis s'était répété on
prouve le contraire tant mieux horizons
différents et profil différent de la
parité déjà avec six femmes et six
hommes mais aussi la jeunesse en
témoigne victor baylacq 20 ans c'est la
diversité et c'est l'espoir en fait
c'est la diversité de tous les profils
de cette union des partis de gauche
écologistes et c'est l'espoir l'espoir
de ce troisième tour et de dire ça y est
on peut peut-être vraiment changer les
choses un autre monde est encore
possible la force et le programme
l'union elle s'est faite autour d'un
programme et on donne aux électeurs
électrices une perspective de victoire
qui est crédible et qui est sérieuse las
nubes c'est un programme mise en commun
mais aussi un combat contre la majorité
présidentielle
je suis candidate pour prendre la place
de béatrice piron elle a voté tout ce
que lui a demandé de voter macron et
c'est tout c'est en fait la députée mme
acronis de base donc moi mon objectif
c'est d'être de prendre sa place pour
porter la voix de tous ceux qui ne sont
pas représentés à l'assemblée nationale
il nous faut comme à grignon dire stop
un autre monde est possible quelque
chose d'autre est possible où nous
pouvons tous ensemble vivre au mieux les
français doivent voter s'exprimer s'ils
veulent un changement de politique dans
ce pays il faut qu'ils viennent voter
cette volonté de cohabitation entre
assemblée nationale et gouvernement
portées par les candidats mieux ps aura
la réponse du peuple dans moins d'un
mois verdict les 12 et 19 juin prochains